thank you thank you everyone for being
here with me and I'm going to give you
some tips and how to win a hackathon and
as you seen in the screen I won the
t-mobile Amazon big data hackathon for
the best model it was um in March and it
was my very first hackathon and in
Mexico this kind of thing doesn't exist
really the area where I was living and
when I came to the US it was a nice
surprise to win that one and then later
on in May I went to become a judge and
for expedition hacks and it was so much
fun because this was a different kind of
hackathon it was more on the structured
data and I was able to get the
experience to become a church and see
many many of the teams working in a big
thank you for kinian because I'm going
to present one her project that was from
the expedition hacks and just by showing
hands how many of you have been in a
hackathon yeah thank you
and how much was the money that they
were giving away
how much was the top prize mm how much
was the private of the hackathon yeah
the second one who was the other one who
went to the hackathon
how was the top prize nothing tough okay
so nowadays the hackathon prices are
going up I start from two thousand one
thousand up to ten thousand and I got to
know that there are hackathons that they
even do the big price of 1.2 million
dollars I heard about that way and
basically what I'm going to tell you is
how to divide your project for the
hackathon in three very simple steps is
one and so organization process and
delivery
and hopefully at the end you all of you
would have the chance to be a winner so
let's just start with organization it's
very important when you start a
hackathon project that you clear a
specific boundaries and expectations
because sometimes when the team is too
big no all the people contribute to the
end goal and also it gets a little bit
messy and more a [ __ ] in the process of
this presentation I'm going to explain
how small groups into a hackathon and
they're winning more frequently that
builds big groups and then the process
list I'm going to divide them in three
areas is one it's preparation is I think
preparation is one of the most important
tasks even when people they could just
go to the hackathon and they just go to
see what you can do at the moment I
think a big key of having a big chance
to win a hackathon from my perspective
what I've seen as a judge is to have a
good framework of the preparation then
at the project framework is to answer
the business question and then at the
end within the model
so which tool of technologies and
technologies you need to be prepared
before going to the event so basically
the most important from my perspective
and what I've seen is you have to have
you a ec2 instance already in place so
try to make sure that everybody in the
team has rated to instance us three
where you are going to put all the data
set and the GPD notebook and anaconda if
you have no idea most of the team's they
were not prepared when they went to the
hackathon with all those two that they
were uploading the programs right there
and then also if
for the even they usually post what kind
of data set you are going to do we do
beam do it and sometime it's already
they have a pretty average data set for
sometimes you need to do web scraping to
have prepare in advance with some
function and going to the second sub
parts step it would be the project
present work we at the end we are
hacking for our customer for our client
even if it is for a nonprofit
organization or for the government at
the end we need to be very specific that
we are solving for our customer for a
client in this case I'm going to present
you with the t-mobile hackathon project
that is a private enterprise and then
I'm going to move with the National
Geographic agency that is a government
project and that is an unstructured data
set so let's go back and how to select
your data system as I said and they
usually present percent you with what
they are going to give you as a data set
or data frame it before the haircut so
they a do the announcement so try to
just to check it out and be prepared see
it is going to be some data sets from
McCulloch competition or if you need to
do some web scraping and also if you are
the scientist or you are not a data
scientist I recommend it usual you are
not at their scientist you go to the
structured data set and just play around
but if you get more complex you can
choose the instructor work and that
would be my recommendation so now let's
go ahead and I'm going to show you just
a little bit of how I made
egman campaign that is the project that
i was i was awarded a the best model for
that hackathon and it was so much fun
and these are some photos of the event
we were presenting and that thing that
is in the background is i pink unicorn
we were presenting there and basically
we were given several dataset and I just
check out all the they did the dataset
and then I realized that there was one
where about direct mail campaign and I
remember that every time I go to my to
pick up my mail I get a bunch of those
kind of advertising advertising and when
most of them were about the some
telecommunication or Internet so I
choose that one is just to be aware of
the of what is out there in the market
and what would be the business question
just to be a little bit aware so I was
lucky to choose that dad one and then he
was at 2,000 features with a 150,000
customers and the business question I
needed to resolve also they don't give
you the business question you need to
come up with the business question in
with the solution so I proposed who is
more likely to respond to a direct mail
campaign and then one little bit of the
algorithm I get a sample of the data set
from all the rows and for the columns
you cannot get a store example you need
to apply an algorithm called PCA
principal component analysis and then I
upside at the results of the principal
component knowledge
with the 90% of the various bias of
datura features population I apply a
bunch of algorithms like logistic
regression I did decision tree and all
of you basically had to have prepared a
function with all the day the normal
machine learning algorithm and the best
one for me was a random forest remember
it's only one day or eight hours of
real-time hacking and so I just choose
the best response er it was random
forest and then what I did is I
activated a duty to instance and then I
inserted put in all the information from
the PCA as load all the data set and I
wrote in the random forest and give me a
good prediction power and I'm going to
show you them this is the repository and
you can check it out and I put a very
simple it's just we load the data set we
apply PCA and you can see this function
and I choose an area person of the virus
I just couldn't have to have something
to print out and then I just random
forest and in here I put I got a score
of 80% then but this is this project was
in my local notebook I don't have the
notebook from there into instance but I
am planning to upload it by next week
when we have the release all of the
other slides and not booked for PI data
Sierra and now let's go to the second on
structured data set for the sector SEC
of projects this was very interesting
because it was my very first time where
I become a judge and I got a very nice
input from the organizers where they
told me that um that I did good
questions for for the the presenters
and I really I learned a lot about the
process and I just came here to tell you
from the perspective of my judge what we
really care about that project in a
hackathon and this one is how to curate
a muse for top national advisor in mind
that you have your trump advisor and you
have to give the him the top news of the
world and what the teams were doing is
try no but we're trying to give them the
most relevant news that they were doing
every day and for this I have I don't
have photos but I have a nice video and
please put half check it out the video
because I have one question and the
person who answers the question is going
to be being given a book and Python and
visualization and it's only two minutes
a very short video but it's nice just
for you to see the experience of a
hackathon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
three two one
Rebecca and 20 years ago and happened
often that we enhanced the official
Intelligence Agency I've been working on
a small team at NBA to identify how
perfect we apply solution for them and
even written between each problem of
getting total topology makers that we
wanted to come out here if you need
ideas say like this sort of awesome
power
Wow gals that have a perspective that we
have seen before
they've come up to maybe is penis memory
probably found problems we hadn't
realized for
we go tonight I'm 31
our project is no loft news so far the
configuration worked well aim for the
curators to us preparing the briefing
look for various
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight's winner goes to sender for
their talkative idea of waiting and
decision-making and impressive slot
[Music]
[Applause]
and for the workplace letter that gets
$10,000 we can get your whole play from
our buddy
[Music]
whether it no I choose
[Music]
yes this is a really great mansion super
awesome Thank You mga
[Music]
so that's why Severus rescued us like a
telenovela I love it so the question is
on how many people and what was the
gender of the winner team okay okay so
shake at the book thank you thank you
[Applause]
so in this in the project that I'm going
to present from the Hakata is something
similar that with the winner as the
winner team the only difference is that
the winner team for the hackathon just
they just added in the UI application
they are three places score like red
yellow and green and if they add the top
adviser of would choose the applications
they use dismiss or accept the news that
they really liked from the algorithm
that they were given and so this um the
model of this project was that they they
had to do web scraping from all the the
news um fit fitness and then they with
that information they use some text text
feature extraction with the tf-idf they
just basically do the big matrix of the
word and they're ranking of course
before that they had to do some cleaning
of the data to the steam and steam
steamer it's called and then they added
the advisors and as
and they do some classification and when
the winner team they just added an extra
feedback point that it was the three
phases from this directing for each
input from the advisors and let's see
them this is the netbook and here you
can see and obviously we could see a
hackathon it nothing is clean and
everybody just draws your data then do
what you you need to do in the moment
and so these are basically the news that
you can see time stamp and then here out
they add just the titles and the name of
the column here they use on the clean
the data set and they use a steamer with
daivam on the punctuation and they do
the they reduce from custom to lower
cups and things like that and now they
added some their roles for example of
the this would be one advisor then I
think is in the international borders as
I so like something like this and
another theory advisor and a mercury
advisor now you have huge data sets and
because they didn't they manually
selected some news and they added for
each one of the advisors as a sample as
a reference for the model and then here
then here now they do the TS vectorizer
the Texas traction features extraction
and now in here they started doing the
night based application of the model and
then they pick all those information
then utilize it in the model and now you
can see some of the suggestions and
these are only the positive and here
they running again and at the end they
just keep some format for the
predictions they are going to give it to
the top advisors and here you have a
bunch of news and now they call the
result let's do the let's check out the
North Korea results and here this is
what the top advisors will be in
suggestion to to a person like the
president Trump to check out the menu
that they were the top priorities news
about North Korea so that was nice
and nowadays can be very basically UNL
with five minutes of of presentation
just three minutes on real time
presenting your project and two minutes
of Q&A and you have no idea when I was a
judge to see how many people they did
very interesting on algorithms and very
nice UI but at the end of when they were
presenting the project they couldn't
deliver the business question of be
precise about what their project were
talking about or even some of them they
talk about that they had a proprietary
algorithm and they had very high
prediction power but at the end they
couldn't say the basic pipeline of the
algorithm so it they at the end we as a
judge we didn't have the certainty if
they really had that great nice
algorithm so it is is incredibly
important that that that in only five
minutes do I you are going to or either
win the $10,000 and had some of the
results from the hard work that you did
for one and a half days and from my
perspective I'm going to give you this
is how we evaluate each of the teams
it's very basic it's just a five-star
ranking and we just have those three
minutes for us to evaluate the whole
project and the whole hard work that
you've been doing for the last one and a
half days or two days depended of the
ricotta and at the end and we have a
matrix like this and in this case not
lost news this is just data by the way
and sometimes it's very close to the
ranking or that we decide that just
based on the presentation of the Q&A
question who is going to win or
something
happen also is that even if the winner
is on the top we believe that the
algorithm for example the proprietary
algorithm doesn't exist because we don't
have any proof and we cannot check it
out with from the notebook we we totally
dismiss that that team and we put it at
the bottom after we proceed to the
delivery of talking about all the the
projects and team so this is one of the
example of the projects who presented
and now is the speech three minutes is
lekha so fast they pass so fast and
usually I am in the teams from our
prospective as a judge and talking with
people who organized constantly
hackathon all over the United States or
even around the world they say the
mostly the the most efficient
presentations come from small teams and
also because they have more precise
information they get less messy around
and usually who give the presentation is
the web developer of the data scientist
but I usually recommend that for the
speech it could be anyone just to be
clear with the following with with some
of these perspectives like in the
interview you need to be very clear and
first say your name and your title
because it's important for us as a judge
to know which kind of people were
involved in the team because if you if
you create a project and you don't have
a data scientist now we know that we we
should know ask you they design this
question of algorithms complex algorithm
question and that would be very relevant
in that if you put that the statement in
the intro and then very quickly a few
seconds later just stage the project why
was it what was your business Square
and what is the answer what and go very
specific and then mentioned your
algorithms and if you said that you had
very high prediction power or if you had
a very nice algorithm please please
don't say that is proprietary because if
you say that even if it is preparatory
just give some idea of the pipeline that
you just use PCA then you use random
forest or you use of web scraper and
there's add feature extraction and then
I base that's all you don't need to give
some information about the feature
engineering Judy for that algorithm to
be so precise at knife and also it's
nice for us as a church to hear how the
project boobies came and how would be
the input the reason there is a winner
for the $10,000 per one it was because
he had for a scaling he had the three
phases anyway so minor but just three
phases that was going to be the input
from any sort of crowdsourcing that they
would put these news talks
the news is good these news is working
this is tech news or something like that
but you have this you have the input and
you you can do some balance of your
model with that input extra information
scaling information from the Crowder's
and at the end you them you demo could
be a dummy one or create just a
PowerPoint presentation presentation as
far as you have very strong business
question algorithm under scaling and if
you don't have that you can do something
very nice as I come through the three
phases UI and also it's very important
that you reiterate the business question
and all of this in three minutes so you
are going to talk very fast but you were
to be very precise and then for the Q&A
I don't strongly suggest that the Q&A
would be the data scientist of the
person who developed the whole pipeline
because what I what we heard during the
presentation of those who Tim and during
the hackathon is that sometimes the
presenter was not the real the the true
person who knows all the tricks and
treats of the project and even when they
presented on nice algorithms he couldn't
explain because what they had were the
model they use or Werdum or what
interface they they would use and how
they would improve it so I highly
suggest for the unite two to switch the
microphone if the presenter is somebody
else that the data scientists of the web
developer and for the Qun I am this is
another very nice pipeline to follow is
get to not do judges for example if
somebody asked me as a data scientist is
asking your question about your
algorithm and is asking you about the
naivebayes don't tell not don't tell
that the ninth ways is a classifier no
no you should tell something about this
the posterior that you use something
very insightful about your algorithm
algorithm because i'm talking about that
the scientist as a judge of if you have
somebody as that is into for example we
have somebody from qi coat and and
jaguar girl and he was asking more
question about and how would you scale
this project now how do you make it more
friendly for the user would user
friendly and just get to know your
judges and then for the data scientists
that are in your team
explain your algorithm and explain how
you build the skills and your algorithm
in the future with more information and
for the web developer is information
about your application and the interface
so basically I'm telling you the same
that for the QA just have those two guys
adhering have the microphone in and you
will be fine I think from my perspective
I mean if you ended up being a winner
and you win $10,000
so you practically would have a lot of
money to go to PI and please please we
are so much fun
please invite us say thank you that
would be all from my side thank you
[Applause]
questions
are we on pepper that's right okay no
well sorry guys
there we go all right so you were
mentioning how in the project stage in
the presentation you kind of go over
your business question and then the demo
you go over it again and I was kind of
curious could you give me like a short
example of how you would do it in step
two and project and versus step three in
the demo to like kind of like figure
that out better I'm sorry I could do yes
so you were mentioning that in the
presentation when we give it to the
judges that are you when you're
presenting the product for to do your
intro and then you do your project and
you show the demo and you said okay when
you're explaining what your product does
and you use your dummy data and stuff
like that you know you want to go over
the business question in the project
stage and then the demo you want to
cover that again and I was curious if
you feel like explain to me like what
are you covering again but you like what
do you suggest we go over this time but
in the demo stage oh it's just because I
mean during the project presentation you
start with the business question and how
you answer and then you explain how we
use this algorithm and this pipeline and
then we end up with these results
and now the let's play the demo and in
the demo you know it is usually an
usually an application then you do do
your task but you have to reiterate and
now with this this demo we are solving
this business question is what I mean
that you close your three-minute speech
saying what you are resolving with your
project yes other questions oh when Zack
hang on second
well that's good I kept my exercises I
was wondering if you had any tips for
like getting a team together and like
practicing before the actual competition
what kind of things we should do thank
you yes thank you so what I would
recommend is that you keep your team
very small like two or three people at
the most and also try to if you want to
do some some unstructured data set try
to have you on your function for web
scraping already already in place and
just call them and try to do some sample
data it's what I would recommend and
also what I really would recommend that
everybody in your team should have
anaconda which you have the jebaited
notebook because if the data science is
finished with their algorithm they want
to send to all of the people to get to
check out the algorithm and to to get to
just to talk about how how you can
improve very quickly and you do pipeline
so that is whether from my perspective I
answer
anything else oh one more
another question about the team do most
people come in with a team or if you
don't you know maybe know a web
developer like Ken so people kind of
meet up and form their teams there so
mostly the team already comes in already
with your friends or you're somebody
that you know but sometimes you get to
meet people over there in the place and
just for this the winner of the of the
hackathon last hackathon it expedition
hug they where they just met over there
so it could be either wait in and you
can haha captain it's a big surprise for
me and I think every time you go to a
very nice hackathon where they give you
food is like a big pie and you end up
making friends with some of the people
and it would be awesome if you don't
have a team or do you don't have any
people that they can go with you that
you just crush the pie and try to
connect with somebody and try to make
something even if you know just that you
don't have a possibility to win because
that is what happened to me I thought oh
I'm not going to win I'm just going to
have fun and create something I am
they're winning the biggest model so you
can't you have a chance everybody has a
chance if you just go on and have fun
and connect with people thank you all
right well thank you very Lisa please
[Applause]